在FDE也沒有出來之前
我們都很希望
就是
企業內部
就是從企業的關口
我們按一個按鈕
就能完成任務
像我剛才那個樣子
對不對
我說了一句話
他就跟我做完一件甚麼事情
我乾嘛乾嘛
但實際上
這個是在今年之後
他才能實現的東西
前兩年你根本想不得想
前兩年的時候
大多數的自動化
他其實講的是這件事情
最開始的時候
講的就是我們所說的提示詞
就是你寫了一個好的提示詞
模板
然後每一次的時候
把這個提示詞模板
為了AI
他幫你跑一份甚麼樣的東西出來
這是我們當時AI剛出來的時候
第一個所謂的自動化
第二個自動化
是我們所說的工作流的搭建
我們知道大家有沒有聽過
扣子這個平台
有嗎
很多人點頭
你們有用過扣子嗎
有
現在還在用嗎
好
搖火了
對
它是時代的一個眼淚
它是自己花了很多的錢
構建的一個
這個我們說叫工作流的平台
但到現在來說
它已經就是
因為發現這個行業真的變得很快
無論是大廠出的產品也算沒有
花很多的時間
學搭建
但實際上沒甚麼用的地方
那個時候
其實第二個階段
其實就是工作流
這一直持續到去年的上半年
可如果扣還沒有開始流行的時候
那大家還是會說
扣子很好用
扣子很愛
該實際上它的搭建也好
或者它的這種
使用過程中的這種
就我們所說的
就是出現的問題
怎麼去拆解
很難搞
那個時候除了扣子以外
還有其他的產品
跟小紅書上面也
火過一段時間的
Apple
包括Defy
都是
其實時間不長的
就去年的時候的產品
但實際上去年非常火
到今年已經
你基本上在市面上
聽不到太多他們的聲音
這是我們所說的
第二個自動化的一個過程
第三個其實是Agent
加Skew
也就是我們在現在來說的
就是昨天到今天
交代一下那個部分
這是現在比較流行的一個方式了
但這個東西大多數的時候
是撥個人
那對於企業來說的時候
現在已經開始去搭自己的Agent
搭自己的工作台
這是現在很多的企業
在實施的部分
也是我們經常會去幫企業做的事情
那除了這些以外
其實像是
企業裡面自己
最低成本
可以去做的事情是甚麼呢
就是例如說
你去搭一個
飛速度多位表格
就可以幫你實現很多的內容
因為它裡面已經內嵌了
AI的功能
只是它不像一個Agent
能幫你推進所有的事情
但因為它裡面內嵌了
大五行這些事情
它可以幫你做到
是類似我們昨天所說的這個出圖
有沒有看到
我昨天給大家練的這張表格
它是能做到這些事情的
這個就是我們所說的
扣子啊
N-B-I-N這些流程的
我當時自己也花了很多時間去學習
我現在想起來真的是傻
對不對
還有流傳一句話呢
叫做
叫做AI這個事情
只要你學的夠慢
你就不用學
對不對
所以但是我相信
你們學了我今天這堂課之後
你會發現這些東西是持久的
因為這些東西是我從二三年到現在的一個層面
我不是教大家去用某一個工具
而是把裡面的原理去給大家說清楚
為甚麼是這個樣子
所以
我
但當然了
也有可能有一天
出來一個AI
所有我說的這些內容已經在裡面了
但是我相信
今天能來到現場的大家
應該還是比較先進的
那當時還有些N-B-I-N的搭建
我給大家看一個過程了
可以幫助你凌晨的
並且低分險的
去批量的獲取小紅書
某個關鍵詞底下的報告文章
達到這樣的一個效果
你可以看到
你可以抓下它的標題證文
以及圖片
還有它的各種數據
那這樣一個工作流
實際上
一共只有5個節點來組成
並且它是非常好操作的
那今天這個視頻
就教大家手把手的
來搭現這個工作流
從MCP的配置
到最後各種節點的
具體的操作
那首先我們在開始之前
我們先理解一下
這整個流程是甚麼樣的
首先我們要輸入自己的
感興趣的關鍵詞
然後這個時候就輪到我們的AI agent
他來調用某一個AI大模型
來操縱這個
看到這裡大家是不是已經暈掉了
我反正當時看到這裡的時候
我已經不知道他在講甚麼了
就是因為裡面會出現
非常多的名詞以及內容
我給他看這個視頻
不讓大家去學M-by-m
我只是出來一個反變教材而已
就是他雖然說他這個東西只有5個節點
但你會發現你後面要你操作的東西無窮度
你看他整個視頻有二三十分鐘
整個的視頻都是讓你配置這些參數啊
配置甚麼內容
非常多這種複雜的內容在
所以當時
我M-by-m流行的時候
作為我們這種叫甚麼
AI的先驅嘛
對吧
就犧牲掉了這一批
AI的先驅先去學習了
學習到這一步的時候
我真的放棄了
真的
一天的時間
全部耗在各種的這種接口
申請賬號
搭建
雖然他最開始告訴你
只有5個步驟
但我花了一天的時間
然後我還沒有搭完
跑到前面幾步
一直在報錯
因為我不是一個編程出生的
我相信大多數的點點不是
這件事情
為甚麼他會覺得簡單
因為他是一個程序員
所以很多的程序員
在網上交東西的時候
他喜歡以程序員的視角
教你這個事情
但很多的名詞
我們甚至懂都不懂
所以這就是一個最大的問題
我也潛伏到了他們的群裡面
我潛伏到這個群裡面
我會發現一件事情
你看裡面其實有很多的程序員
但是這些程序員
他其實也在問問題
叫做為甚麼這裡又壞了
為甚麼這裡又乾嘛了
所以當時這個東西
要去搭一個這個成本非常高
就是我們可以
那個時候最簡單的一個方式
我們花錢找這個人去搭
但是你如果要自己學
搭建的那個事情
真的是反人性
真的非常反人性
我只是列出來
讓大家看一下而已
那我們說到自動化
包括我比較推薦大家的方式
就像我剛才一樣
去做一個SKU
當你做完了一個SKU之後
你就可以去把你日常的工作
去放在這個SKU裡面
資料也好
或者是一些數據也好
一些我們所說的
這個小的腳本型的工具也好
放進去了之後
你想要怎麼做
你通過一句話的方式
去跟他講這個事情
他就能幫你把這件事情做完
那甚至說你可以
如果你是一個企業
你是可以去搭建這種工具
或者是這種看板
讓你手下的員工
因為你不能指望你手下的員工
每個人都很不會有偉拈
你只能指望他
不會用你搭建的偉拈就OK了
所以你需要去
可以去說去搭一些這樣的看板
或者有內容
去讓別人去做這件事情
那我們因為現在還有一些老闆
我也想給大家科普一個事情
叫做如何去實現
找到並實現自己企業的AI化路線呢
我們離不開現在所說的一個詞
叫FDE
甚麼是FDE呢
知道FDE的請舉個甚麼
不是
來
知道了
有沒有人知道他甚麼意思
其實他核心是Engineer
就是他是一個工程師
FDE的意思是
就等於說
假設我們的合作了
我就派幾個工程師去你們公司
幫你做AI化路線
就是這個道理
就等於說你公司沒有AI能力嘛
對吧
我派幾個人去幫你把這個工作的全搭了
那他其實的來源
其實是Parentier的這家公司
他們做這種部署
包括這種我們所說的
他們是從SARS的那個時代開始的
然後開始去給各種公司
去做數字化轉型
到現在去做AI化轉型的這件事情
其實美國極其出名的一家公司
也是這個行業的一個先驅
那我們說叫做甚麼
企業的AI時代
其實像是OpenAI
包括Enterofic
我們前面所說的這些AI巨頭
他們也在開始去說
自己招自己的FDE工程師
我去幫你們企業去搭這個事情
所有人都在做這件事情
因為我們說AI時代到來
沒有一家企業的信品
所有的企業都需要或多或少的去進步
那在這個裡面呢
其實FDE它本身就是把AI從最開始
你可能知道了
AI能做這些事情
但你在搭建過程中
一定有出現任何問題
你就不如來找專業的人做這些事情
這樣的一個詞意
那企業很多時候
你卻買了一些工具
買了一些模型
但其實用到現在
我前面給大家貼個圖
美團的這個網普中
他們都發了就是說
裝了所有的小龍腔
每天花了這麼多錢
結果還反而對自己的業務流程
產生了阻礙
那其實本質上是有甚麼原因
其實就是沒有打通
那本身是業務流程的問題
所以我們核心
用AI不是為了用AI
用AI是為了業務更好的精進
以及效率的平生
那你純粹去買一個模型
買一個工具
其實是沒有用的
而更多的是需要基於自己的業務
去做AI化的落地改造
有像我一樣
我給大家一件事的
我以前寫東西是手寫的
我以前收集書寫是手收集的
用腦騰訊收集的
現在全部都是AI自個化
保網絡的事做完它
那落下來
好的FDE
它其實需要具備一些能力
因為你們肯定到後面
也會去找到這樣的公司
去給你們做一些服務
那它可能需要具備甚麼能力呢
首先可能需要有工程的交付能力
它一定要懂一些代碼形式的內容
那就是說他們團隊
一定要有工程師性質的人
第二是它要理解企業的邊界
以及AI的邊界
它要知道怎麼更好的
去融合到一起
第三它要懂你的業務
它要坐在你的業務員的旁邊
去觀察它到底是怎麼工作的
從而去不打破你們原有的
這個業務流程的情況下
就可以給你們構建一套
適配你們的方式
所以這其實是我們所說的
好的FDE的一個地方
那在這個裡面
其實我們自己會建議大家
如果說在場的有些老闆
大家想去做這件事情
我們會比較建議大家
去做這幾件事情
就是你不要一上來了之後
去找一家FDE公司去簽約
或者是去招這樣的一個崗位
我們現在也看到很多的
企業的招聘這樣的一些崗位
但招進來我們之前公司也招過
但招完之後就發現
它待不了兩個月它就會走
經常會出現這樣的一個問題
原因是甚麼
它沒有辦法融入你們的業務的場景
因為可能大家的這個認知程度
包括這種業務的融合度
沒有那麼好
所以這其實就是一個最大的問題
那我們自己最近現在實踐下來
比較好的一個方式
其實很核心的
有一個點是場景
有一些場景是適合的
有一些場景是不適合的
你如果想要推行這些事情
最重要的是找到一個能做下來
以及能讓大家有信心的場景
在做的過程中
因為企業老闆經常在花錢
要支出這些費用給到這些FDE
那他的心理人就會在想一個問題
這麼久了怎麼還沒看到這個成果呢
對不對
經常會有這個事情
但這個成果的問題
有可能不是FDE來來的
是因為你們企業本身的數字化
要做好
所以它的效果可能沒有那麼好
那在這個情況下
就會出現一個情況
就是我們最開始介入的時候
一定要選到一個高頻
且沒有那麼複雜的場景去做
給彼此接近信任跟信心
那第二
就是要去選對人跟團隊
就是一個公司有很多的部門
你要從哪個部門開始AI化
你要從哪個部門開始這種基建
那這個也是很重要的
有一些業務重的
你可能就不太適合
廣光廣然的去介入
可能會影響
整個業務的正常的進行
那我們可能會選擇
我們自己
類似說
你去改造一些理方的企業
就廣光公司
那會乾嘛
我們會去挑選一些小團隊
類似說
它是一個業部
它專門FORM
某一類的客戶
它可能只有幾個人
我們會選擇這種小團隊
先去介入
讓他們先跑起來
這樣的話
既不會阻礙你們公司的正常業務
又能夠讓這個模式成為一個好的模式
那然後去試點
然後再去上線
交接以及復用
而且FDE它不是一件
類似說
我給你簽了一個單
我幫你交付了一套系統
它就能解決的問題
因為AI
你像我們今天講的所有內容
其實是三年內的內容
它的變化的過程
從剛才的那個自動化
裡面也能看出來
可能類似說
你去年的時候
找一些FDE來給你進駐
它給你搭了一套扣子
花了幾十萬
結果到中間出現了各種問題
你要想到今天
其實它就細節損好
而且它也不會用
所以現在我們說
跟企業去合作
做AI這件事情
大多數的時候
更多的是應該以一個
培訓培考資訊的
這樣的一個角度去切入
等於說我們要陪伴
你們去做好
類似說認知的升級
以及說接下來的
這種內部的改造
那件事情
所以這其實是一個
正確的合作的一個關係
所以講到這裡
其實核心是
就是為了讓大家
認知到現在整個行業
發生一些甚麼樣的事情
就是如果你今天想要給企業
做變化改造
這個詞你是已經離不開了
這個崗位或者這樣的一個企業
這樣的一個合作夥伴
你一定是離不開的
所以也是給大家做一個小小的普及
那講到這裡
我的部分就基本上講完了
再給大家簡單的回顧一下
內容是比較多的
昨天講了甚麼東西
行業的變化
以及認知的框架
以及包括
Agent 加模型
找到先採密工具
這一部分其實是一個
認知加工具的地方
下面
這就是3 這陣4
昨天下午
下午後面的那部分
它其實有非常多的場景
都是大家的職場
那些日常工作裡面
經常會用到的場景
信息減數
穩圖視頻的生產
以及數據分析
到今天上午
我們講了甚麼
講了提示詞
而SQ的構件
以及剛才所說的
這個企業化落地的這個事情
那總結來說
你們發現一件事情
叫甚麼
叫短短三年
就好像跨過了一個起點
甚麼是起點
就是量變
達到自變的那個點
前幾年大家都還在
說AI增效
AI增效
今年突然就變成了
AI要砍人了
老闆
老闆經常會問我們的一個問題
就是那個問題
就是我跟你們合作了
我能不能把我們20的員工砍掉
20%的員工砍掉
天天都問我們這個問題
我們說我沒辦法給你們包票的
因為這個事情其實我們還要看
因為AI它還沒有說完全成熟
但是從目前來說
很多的小額美的公司
它反而通過
AI的不斷強化學習
跑得比很多的大公司很快
所以這其實就是一個
很核心的一個變化了
那我們
我們教了非常多的內容
我們核心的問題
就是AI怎麼用
然後這個東西
其實你除了今天我們的學習以外
我相信大家已經有了一個比較好的體系的觀感
然後你們再去看網上的資料的時候
你就大概知道工具的細節